Hi and thank you so much for coming today
and taking time out of your very busy
schedules to listen to me
Yammer on about my book. Um,
it's called the vanishing season and it
just came out last week and it had an
unusual path to publication in that
it won the mystery writers of America,
uh,
slash St Martins [inaudible]
debut crime novel award,
which is an annual contest that is
held in conjunction with St Martin's,
my publisher and the
mystery writers of America.
So it's open to anybody who
has a unpublished manuscript.
So if you have an unpublished manuscript
lying around that has to do with crime,
you can shine it up and send it in.
The new deadline is mid January of
2018 and they usually get about 400
submissions.
And the mystery writers of America
have some judges who comb through those
manuscripts and narrow it down
to a handful of finalists,
which are then sent on to the editors
at Saint Martins who pick the winner.
And occasionally there's no winner.
Uh,
but my year I won, which I was very
surprised and delighted to find out,
which is how my book came to be.
So that was March, 2016 when
they said, yes, we like it,
we will publish it. And it just
came out now about 22 months later.
So it's a long journey,
um,
from the decision to publish to the
actual presentation of the book.
But it's been exciting and
fun. I recommend it, you know.
Uh,
and um,
so the book is about, one of the
reasons I thought that it might not,
when is most of the winners have
been kind of traditional mysteries or
historical mysteries that don't
feel feature a lot of, um,
grit or, uh, well,
body parts is my mother calls my
novel, the body parts novel. Uh,
so I was very surprised where
they picked me and my body parts,
uh, add delighted but surprised. And um,
it's about a serial killer who,
uh,
well who's active in, um, a small
town in Woodbury and Massachusetts.
It's fictional.
And a living in this town is
my heroine Ellery Hathaway,
who was,
has personal knowledge of a serial
killer cause she was kidnapped off the
streets of Chicago as a 14 year old to the
eve of her 14th birthday. Actually, uh,
she was alone outside on the streets
at night because her mother was in the
hospital with her brother who was dying
of cancer and the father had run off
years ago. So LRA was vulnerable. Um,
and when the sedan pulled over,
it's a hot night in Chicago,
oppressive heat. She
thought, well, if I help him,
maybe he'll give me a dollar
for a soda and I can cool off.
But instead he got out of the
car and her life changed forever.
She would have been victim number 17 of,
uh,
Francis Coben who is an infamous
Ted Bundy type serial killer, uh,
who had a ducted and killed 16 girls
before and he kept the hands and ditch the
rest. And so Ellery was, um,
in prison by him and would
have been killed too,
if not for a very green FBI agent who
was like low man on the totem pole in the
investigation.
But he played a hunch and serendipitously
rescued her from the closet.
Um,
and that was 14 years before the book
opens and now she's living in anonymity.
She's changed her name. She's trying
to put all the past behind her,
but every year around her birthday
somebody goes missing from this small town
and they all seem to have, well most of
them seem to have reasons to be missing.
So nobody's very surprised
and there wasn't,
they aren't looking for them too hard in
most cases and they don't see a pattern.
But Ellery gets a creepy clown
birthday card in the mail.
After each disappearance
it says happy birthday.
Ellery and she doesn't really
talk about a birthday much.
So this is a signal to her that somebody
knows who she is for real and uh,
the person may be dangerous,
but she can't get anybody to believe her
that these disappearances are connected.
And to explain the whole story
risks outing her past and again,
being forced to deal with this ugly serial
killer who had hurt her when she was
a teenager. Um, so this
year the, you know,
the vanishing season is coming around
again and somebody is going to go missing
unless she can figure
out a way to stop it.
So she calls up the one guy she knows
will believe her and that's read Markham,
the FBI agent who rescued her
when she was 14 and Reed's life,
uh, skyrocketed, uh, after
his, uh, rescue of LRA,
he wrote a bestselling book about it.
He got promoted,
he became a hot shot profiler.
Uh, it was great. He hits,
he met his wife kind of this way where
she was starstruck a little by the whole
serial killer. You catch serial
killers. That's really cool. Um,
and uh,
so the best time of his life basically
is the worst time of [inaudible] and
that's why they're interesting
to put together as they,
they had their identities forged by this
initial terrible case and they've both
been living with it in different ways
ever since. So for read, it's been a boon,
you know, gave him fame and
fortune and for LRE it, you know,
has been awful obviously.
And so forcing them to back together
again for a causes them to confront those
roles where you know, for read,
if Ella is life isn't awesome.
I mean he's always told himself he's the
big hero of her story. He rescued her.
She's the one that lived. Um,
if her life isn't so awesome,
then maybe he's not the hero.
He told himself he was. Um,
and for Ellery she's always sort of a
told herself she's going to be the victim
forever. Like she's forever tied to
this very famous serial killer. Uh,
and so now she has a chance to see like
who she might be apart from that story.
Um, so that's kind of the
main thrust of the book.
And one of the questions I get asked
a lot is where did it come from?
And the genesis of the story
was about 20 years ago.
I was reading one of the stories about
Ted Bundy and there are a lot of them,
there's a new Ted Bundy story.
Every year, basically a movie TV,
movie, a book, something like this
story, you know, it's 40 years old,
but it keeps getting retold.
And so ted Bundy lives on, um,
and for the people who were
caught up in his story, uh,
this can be difficult to have to keep
reliving it when the public won't let it
die basically.
And um,
so he has living victims,
uh,
one of whom is a woman
named Carol [inaudible].
Carol was 18 and shopping at a
Utah shopping mall when Ted Bundy,
uh,
pretending to be a police officer,
told her that her car had been broken
into and she needed to come with him to
the police station and make a report.
And so she got into the car with him
and it was immediately struck that this
doesn't look like a cop's car.
And then he drove her,
not towards the police station,
but away from it.
And so she freaked out and
demanded to be let out of the car,
at which point Bundy realizes that the
Jig was up and he had to subdue her
somehow. So he pulled over
the road side of the road.
And He tried to snap his handcuffs on her,
but in the struggle he got
both the cuffs on one wrist.
And so she was able to escape and she
became the beginning of Ted Bundys end
because they,
people sort of knew that he was out there,
this guy named Ted and there
were the missing girls and um,
they were probably connected,
but they didn't really,
they didn't know what he looked like,
all these sorts of things.
And she was able to say,
here's what he looked like,
here's the car he was driving and the
cops were able to start putting the pieces
together. So Carol, um, today,
so more than 40 years after this incident
still gets 10 to 15 messages per day
about Ted Bundy. People
write her saying, oh, he,
he kidnapped me to, um, or they say,
uh, Oh, tell me what Ted's
really like. What was it like?
They want her story.
A couple of years ago,
some guy decided to say he was her son
and like he has this connection to Ted
Bundy.
She doesn't have a son.
So she was forced to come for either let
this lie perpetuate or to come forward
and say, I don't have a son. He's lying.
So Bundy has been dead for decades.
He was electrocuted in Florida in 1989.
Um,
but for Carroll, he's there
every day. You know, the,
her life now became,
you know,
about Ted Bundy and the public
won't let him go for her.
She has no choice.
Um,
another person caught up in the Ted
Bundy story would be the read Marcom type
character. And this was Bob
capital who was brand new.
He had been on the job as a homicide
detective one week when he got handed the
Ted Bundy case.
And this completely changed the
trajectory of capital's career.
He ended up specializing
in serial murderer.
He hunted Bundy for years until
they caught him. Um, he actually,
when they Bundy was finally apprehended
for good cause he escaped Weiss. Uh,
he was when he was finally an
apprehended for good in Florida.
Keppel traveled there and interviewed
him multiple times and was able to get
Bundy to confess for two more murders
that they didn't know he'd even committed.
Um, eventually Keppel went
on to specialize in serial
murder and try to help,
uh, classify them to see if we could
figure out how to get serial killers.
Um, is there an learn more about how
they think, where do they come from?
So he participated in
some scientific research.
He ended up lecturing teaching
about serial killers. Uh, you know,
it also took over his life in a more
positive way and that he was the expert in
serial murder. Um, but again,
like it was serendipity, right?
He's just a guy,
he and working for the Seattle police,
when all of a sudden this call comes in
about a missing girl and now he's been
handed one of the most infamous
cases in all of history.
So I was less struck when I read
this book about Ted Bundy himself.
He's very interesting.
But all of these side people,
the people who were approached
by Bundy and didn't go with him.
So I know somebody who was living in
the sorority house that he attacked in
Florida.
Uh,
he broke in and just basically went
from room to room beating women,
these young women with a log and he
killed some of them and gravely injured
others. There was one who
was going to be a dancer. Um,
and the head injury caused her life to
be rewritten because she had balance
issues after that. And so she lived,
but her life was never the same.
And the woman I know lived there,
but it wasn't home that night.
She was out. So it's, you know,
the sort of sliding doors parallel lives.
Like what if she had been there?
She wasn't. Um, but still it's
something she thinks about frequently.
When you have a brush with a, an
infamous case like this, it changes you.
And so the book is about serial murder
and there's a mystery and who did it and
all that other stuff.
But it's also about what it's like to
live attached to this infamous crime.
How many people are
familiar with mind hunter?
Very popular Netflix series right now.
I see one.
So mine hunter is,
uh,
based on the work of two other
people who hunted serial killers,
a wrestler and Douglas and they
went around and interviewed them.
They had this idea like,
you know,
Sarah killers have been with us
forever but nobody really studied them.
And they said,
well,
we're going to study them and interview
them and see if we can classify them and
figure out where they come from and help
people catch them. So this is all about,
you know,
their interviews.
They have creepy serial killers are people
playing creepy serial killers and uh,
they show the interviews and how the
work came to be and whether people
supported it at first and
how it gained momentum.
What's interesting about it now
as if you go to the FBI site,
the FBI's basically like,
yeah,
none of that really
panned out like we tried.
But it turns out serial killers are very
hard to catch and they're hard to catch
for a lot of reasons. But one of
the things is all their hard work,
it trying to figure out like, okay,
what can we say about serial killers?
And they could find some tendencies,
like, okay, they tend to be, um,
bed wetters, you know,
into later adolescents.
So they like bedwetting is a problem
even when they're like 10 or 12 or
something like that.
Okay,
well if you suspect you have a serial
killer in your neighborhood and you're a
police officer, you can't really go
like round up the bed. Wetters you know,
like with the saw the cops.
So looking at these profiles going,
they don't help us, like have, you
know, okay, so we had mommy issues,
like how do we go round up the people
who had mommy issues or whatever.
Like this is not helpful.
And then also some of it just turns
out not to be helpful even as a
classification system.
So one of the big things they tried
early on was you could be an organized
killer who would be kind
of like Bundy, who, um,
planned his victims.
And he had this very big rooms where he
would dress up as an injured person with,
uh, um, a cast on. And
he'd say, Oh, come with me.
I need you to help me carry my books.
To my car and the young
woman would go with them,
at which point he would leap
upon them and subdue them.
Or you pretend to be a cop
or something like that.
And he had a plan with how he
was going to just, you know,
be with a victim and kill her and
where he was going to leave her.
And then disorganized killers who
would be, you know, like, Ooh,
I'm just walking along when I'm overcome
with the urge to kill and I break in
and I just killed people.
But one day did that too at the end.
So is he organized or disorganized?
And it turns out like organized killers
have elements that are disorganized and
disorganized killers have elements of
organizations. So this category helped,
not at all,
but there are other things that are kind
of interesting things that appear about
serial killers in movies and television.
Um,
so for example, you see things like, oh,
they always take trophies with them.
That's a big thing.
And it turns out about half,
half takes some sort of trophy,
like some piece of the victims
jewelry or a driver's license.
So they can like relive it
afterward, but only about half. Um,
another one they found serial killers
are more likely to have served in the
military.
So if 1% of the population is served in
the military around now see what killers,
it's one in three.
So probably they're attracted to
the dominance and the weapons and,
and that sort of thing.
But again,
most the vast majority of people in
the military or not serial killers,
so even if you suspect
you have a serial killer,
it's not like you can go round up
everybody in the military and say,
are you the one?
MMM.
And then, uh, let's see other things that
are so true about serial killers, um,
that they kill strangers and
that's why they're hard to catch.
And it turns out about a third
of their victims are strangers.
It turns out the most common relationship
between a serial killer and his victim
is business.
So watch out when you're doing business.
Now prostitution accounts for a good chunk
is app that's classified as business.
But also,
you know,
you go down to your Kinko's to
make some mimeographs or whatever.
And the Siri killer happens to be
working behind the counter. Uh,
so you get those kinds of things too
where there's this casual connection.
You would still mostly be classified as
strangers and you don't really know each
other, but you have met before. Um,
so that's another thing that is sort of
interesting about serial killers. Um,
another one that pops up sometimes
is like, are the victims,
all women on TV,
they're almost always women.
And it turns out in real life
they're mostly women to, um,
it's about 80%.
And again,
part of that is the prostitution because
if you're a serial killer and you're
lazy and you want a victim,
it's very easy to get a prostitute
to get in the car with you.
You don't have to go hunt her and she'll,
you know,
opened the door and she'll get it and
then you are expected to drive her off,
some more secluded. So she
doesn't freak out immediately. Um,
so unfortunately like prostitution,
people who are in the sex trade are
still vulnerable to this kind of thing.
You can call them up and like have
the one delivered to your home. Um,
so that's a chunk of
where that comes from.
So that's about 80% of
the victims are women. Um,
and another one I that I find
interesting, there's this idea that, oh,
they're already in the system somewhere.
If we just look for people who
are out there convict, you know,
committing violent crimes,
we can find the serial killer.
And it turns out,
nope,
that about 80% of them have some
kind of record by the time they are,
uh, arrested for murder. Uh,
but it's usually nonviolent
stuff like peeping or,
um,
simple theft.
It's not really that they're out there
committing these violent crimes and they
have a record. So it turns out they're
actually very, very hard to catch.
So that was one, I got some
feedback on my book actually, um,
about reed and his ability
to profile and everything.
It's a bit like he's not
very good at his job.
Like he gets stuff wrong in
the book and well, I mean,
profiling is not, you
know, a science per se.
It's not like it has the guaranteed
outcome that they're like, okay,
and he's going to be wearing a red
sweater and driving a blue minivan.
It's just like they can't
get it down that far.
And indeed the cops off of get frustrated
because what the profilers will come
forward with or stuff like,
well he's really angry at women
and the cops are like, yeah,
we kind of gathered that from the way
he's killing them. What else? You got?
Nothing of the bed wetter thing. Okay. Uh,
so there is this tension between the
FBI that wants to do this research into
serial killers and the local police who
really just want help catching them when
they think they have one.
Uh,
but this is another problem is
how do you know when you have one?
Because it'd be nice if they were always
very consistent and they like slept.
The sign nodes like the Zodiac,
you, it's me or they always,
you know, used a pair of red
nylons to strangle their victim.
Something obvious. It says, okay,
yeah, these are all related.
But sometimes they're opportunists
and they will change murder weapons.
So one might be a strangulation and
then another will be a shooting. Um,
so they can be very hard to detect.
But what's interesting now is some people
are beginning to experiment with like
big data and it's hard right now
because the way law enforcement works,
they're all segregated.
So you can be a serial killer in one town
and go like across the street and be a
serial killer in another
town in the two towns.
Don't even know that there have related
victims because they're not sharing data.
So there's some people who are making
efforts to try and get the police
departments to share more data.
So you can pick out serial
killers and that's looking like,
it might be an interesting way. Some
people are saying this, this will work,
but it hasn't been rigorously tested yet.
But at least we are probably moving in
the right direction to be able to spot
these guys. And again,
it is mostly guys, uh,
you can't get females.
They are killers.
They tend to murder like serial
husbands, like black widow's. Like,
I'll marry a guy and then often,
um,
for money and then I'll marry
another one off him for money.
And if you move around, this
can be very hard to, uh, catch.
And this is the thing, how do they
finally catch serial killers? Well,
it turns out their families
turn them in, their friends. Um,
the people who know them who can say,
oh yeah, he was a bed wetter or um,
yeah, or you know, and Bundys
case, his fiance was like,
he has a plaster of Paris in the,
um,
bathroom and some handcuffs in the
car that looks suspicious to me.
She had to turn him in three times before
they took her seriously because nobody
thought they were looking
for a law student.
They thought they were looking for
some sort of savage on the street.
He was like foaming at the mouth or
something. Um, so it took a while to,
even though like lots of people
returning Ted and Ted Bundy, like, Ooh,
this guy does drive a VW
bug and his name is Ted.
The cops just didn't believe it could
possibly be him until, you know,
his girlfriend.
Actually turned him in when he moved to
Utah and more women started disappearing
there and she's like, okay, so ted,
move to Utah and now you
have missing women there.
You really might want to check into that.
But what's interesting about Liz,
um, his fiance, she
didn't break up with him.
It's a head scratcher for me. I, so
she kept turning him into the cops.
Like I think he could be a serial killer.
I think he might be the guy.
And then I'm also still gonna marry him.
And indeed one woman did marry him on
death row when he'd been convicted of all
of it, uh, and actually bore his child.
So out there is, uh, a woman who, uh,
would be a little younger than me,
uh, who has ted Bundy for a father.
And her mother is somebody who had sex
with Ted Bundy when he was on death row.
So that's your parentage.
Good luck.
Are there any questions about publishing,
about the book, about serial murder?
I found the, the addressing of the, um,
the emotional scars in the
book. Interesting. It. Um,
uh, it really does feel like that is
a major part of the book as you said,
rather than, than just the, the, the
killer in the hunt for the killer. Um,
it's hard to make such
a thing come across as,
as believable unless you
know, you, you, you have
examples of people with
emotional scars that going,
I guess to some extent we all do.
Did you use any,
any particular examples from
the real world to, to base, um,
LRS behavior and,
and the baggage on?
Um, so, you know, I have the, the
Bundy cases, one of the imprints,
but, um, uh,
actually I was assaulted by a
neighbor when I was five, uh,
repeatedly by,
um,
a neighbor who told me he would
kill me if I ever told my family.
And so I said nothing for several years.
Uh,
he eventually went to jail
for unrelated charges. Um,
but I've always sort of wondered what
parts of my personality or as a result of
that experience and what
would have been me anyway.
There's no control Joanna, that we can
run alongside me to be able to say, okay,
that's how you would have been
if this had never happened. Um,
so it's something that's
interesting to me.
I started checking out books on rape
from the library when I was like eight to
try to understand this whole thing.
So I've done a ton of reading and
I've done writing about it. Um,
and what happens when I write about it is
women come out of the woodwork and say,
yeah,
here's what happened to me.
And so I've been collecting these stories
over the years of different women.
And so LRE is kind of an
amalgamation of all of us. Uh,
her story is very dramatic
because it's famous and you know,
you can't get away from it.
Most of us live in relative anonymity.
So that part is very unusual for Ellery.
Um,
but what's common is, you know,
the shame, the wondering like,
did I do something to cause this,
uh,
the feeling that if somebody knows
what happened to you that it's going to
change how they look at you, how
they feel, how they act to you.
Uh, you know, we've seen this with
like the me too movement, right?
So like a lot of women have some story,
uh,
and most of us are carrying it
around in secret and just the,
the secrecy part of it can
be like a lingering pain.
And so, yeah, LRE is like a
mixture of all of these tales.
Yes. Another question. Uh,
what did you find most surprising
about the publishing process?
Um, most surprising about
the publishing process?
Well, I'm really heartened
that the book is doing well.
Like to me that's the biggest surprise.
I brought eight.
It's a nice little mystery and,
you know, I, I like, but it's like,
it's sold out on Amazon
and six days. Um, you know,
and so people were coming forward going,
I really liked this. And I'm like, oh,
thank you. I'm just surprised every
time. Uh, it terms of like the mechanics,
I would say how long it takes is like,
I sort of knew that intellectually,
but you know, it's 22
months. And as I like to say,
I could have birth to actual children
in that time frame, you know,
instead or one elephant, um, or a book.
And it turns out that there's a lot
of different pieces that go into it.
You know, when you, that my publisher
publishes like 110 mysteries a year.
So you have your slot about, this is
when the editor can focus on your book.
This is when the copy editor can focus
on your book. This is when the, you know,
cover artists can focus on your
book. Uh, and you, you know,
it's a complicated dance and you have
to meet your steps or the whole process.
You can, you can miss your opening and
then your book is delayed even more. Uh,
so it's,
that kind of has been,
I would say the most surprising part.
The thing that surprises
other people is like,
I don't have anything to
do with the cover. Um,
the publisher picks both the title and
the cover for books and authors depending
on their statue or get more or less input.
And so the,
this title actually is mine. Um,
and the publisher agreed to it.
The cover, like I was not even consulted.
They're just like, here it is. Um,
and I provided some feedback and they
made some tweaks on that and I'm very
happy with the way it turned out. But I
know sometimes authors are very unhappy.
Uh, Lisa Gardner was
telling me this week, um,
that they had tweaked her
cover so many times that, uh,
it ended up the woman had
six fingers cause she was so,
she's looking at the coverage,
she's like,
it looks odd to me and then they'll
publish this way. She's like,
it looks odd to me sending her husband,
she says he's more visual than I am.
And he came along, he was like,
that's because she has six fingers.
Oh yeah.
And then even if you are at least a
gardener who has published, you know,
Zillions of a New York
Times bestselling books,
um, still the publisher will
come to you and say, uh,
can you give the heroin Brown eyes are
not brown eyes but green eyes because we
have green eyed art that we
want to use on the cover.
And so brown eyes aren't going to work.
Oh,
can you go back and change
your heritage so that uh,
she has green eyes and
Lisa's, it's like, all right,
I'll just go tweak her heritage.
So she has green eyes in the book.
So the way the different
pieces come together and
where the author can push back
and where the author can is continues
to be a bit of a surprise for me
quickly.
Thank you for that explanation of why
so many books cover pictures don't match
the story inside.
I never understood.
Yeah. Well it turns out this is, you know,
authors actually usually are not very
good at figuring out what to put on the
cover because they imagined that
it's going to be like a scene.
Like you act out a scene from the book
and when it doesn't look like that,
they're like, what? But this
doesn't look like my book. And um,
it turns out that the most important thing
the book can do is signal it's genre,
like what it is. Um, so is
it literary fiction? Is it a,
is it a scary mystery?
Is it a cozy mystery like murder she
wrote where like there's a dead body but
nobody really cares.
Um,
that kind of thing because if you get
it wrong, like the readers are angry,
I've seen reviews where,
you know,
there's something on the cover
that's super creepy and then they,
the book isn't scary and the
readers are mad. They're like,
I really was prepared to
be terrified by this book.
And it wasn't even Martin Lee
thrilling or, um, you know,
this book looks Psi Phi to me.
Uh, and it isn't. And honestly,
even when you get in the genre,
you can still have, um, problems.
So one of my readers apparently
thinks she looks pregnant.
Okay.
And so she read the book expecting the
pregnancy to show up and it never did.
And she was mad. She's like, two
stars off the, uh, cover is a lie.
So you can't,
you can't win,
but you really more than acting out a
particular scene or having the character
look exactly like they're
described in the book, um,
you want it to signal what it is.
So that readers who were like,
you don't want somebody looking
for a pizza to get a cheeseburger.
What can you tell us about your future
work? Oh, what a great question.
So I'm very fortunate.
Uh,
saint Martins has kindly picked up
the next two books in the series A.
So, uh, no mercy is
slated to come out, um,
January,
2019 and then there was another one after
that and it's read and Ellery again.
And the Basset Hound speed bump,
everybody likes the Basset Hound,
so he's back to, and they solve
more crimes. The second book,
um,
Ellery is sentenced to group
therapy with ordinary crime victims.
Like one of them is a survivor. His wife
was killed in a drunk driving accident.
Another one had his buddy die in
a convenience store robbery. Um,
so none of them is famous. Like Ellery,
none of them has like, you know,
crime in big bold letters and Ellory's
like she's been living with it all these
years, so she's not too keen on
getting in touch with her feelings.
So instead some of these
crimes are unsolved, uh, for
her, her fellow survivor.
So she starts trying to solve all their
lives, all their rather than, you know,
doing what she's supposed to.
And then the third one read,
actually his mother was
murdered when he was an infant.
She was found stabbed to death just a
short way away from his crib and he was
adopted.
Um,
and he gets a hot new lead
after 40 years and read an LRA,
go to Vegas to solve his mother's murder.
What would you say is the surprising
part of writing a book maybe compared to
other stuff you've written
in the past? Um, sure. Yeah.
Surprising part of writing a book.
Well, I have to have some surprise.
I discovered very early on that if I,
um,
outline too,
too much of a detailed outline,
I won't write the book because
it's all like, well the,
the hard part is figuring out the exact
phrasing and everything and if the store
is all there, I'm like, well that's
it. I don't need to do that work. Um,
I'll just leave it in my head. Uh,
so I have a rough outline and then,
you know,
things happen where I'm riding along in
a character I didn't think was going to
do something, does something.
All of a sudden it's happening.
And I was like, Ooh,
that's very interesting. I didn't know
you had that secret motive or you know,
this thing and you're past that suddenly
coming out to, to light. I know I'm,
Ian Mckellen said he wrote like 13 books
before he realized his hero was Polish,
you know, like that was his ancestor.
He's like, oh, of course you're Polish.
I didn't know.
So like that's the fun
part is the discovery where
you're riding along and you,
you learn about your characters.
So that's,
I think the surprising part
and the fun part. Thank you.